it's seen as one of the most spectacular
robberies of all time in Germany many
people were left wondering how these
young men could enter such a heavily
secured Museum and steal more than 4 300
diamonds aged between 24 and 29 their
brothers and cousins belonging to the
same family from Berlin on the night of
November 25th 2019 they entered the
green Vault Museum after causing a power
cut that left the neighborhood in
darkness CCTV footage shows two men
inside the walls they smashed glass
displays with an ax days before they'd
sewn opened some of the window grating
so they could get inside quickly their
whole dozens of historical pieces among
them were a diamond-laden brass star of
the Polish order of the White Eagle a
diamond set hat closure and a sword with
777 small diamonds all belonging to the
18th century collection of Augustus de
strong the elector of Saxony who laid
became the king of Poland trying to find
the stolen jewelry fully search canals
in Berlin they found nothing but after
negotiations with several suspects much
of the jewelry was returned one of the
men convicted over the jewelry robbery
and dressed and had previously been
convicted over the theft of a 100
kilogram gold coin from the Berlin
Boulder Museum here behind me
prosecutors in the Dresden case have
been criticized for making a deal with
members of a family known to live of
organized crime
the court defended the decision to make
a deal
without a deal there would have been no
return of a jewelry at least not in the
foreseeable future and it was also clear
that law enforcement authorities had no
idea whether jewelry could be so it
would have been very doubtful whether it
would ever have made his way back to
Saxony
plea bargain three of the convicted men
at their detention suspended and were
released
steadfast in Al Jazeera Berlin